hello everyone and welcome back to the
1972 World Chess Championship match
between Robert James Fisher and Boras
facility with Spassky the result is six
and a half to four and a half but it was
six and a half to three and a half in
the previous game but Spassky won a
brilliant game in around eleven if you
haven't seen it there will be a link in
the description below so feel free to
check it out it was a really spectacular
game
Spassky tackled officials poisoned pawn
variation of denied or very nicely so be
sure to check it out if you haven't and
now it seems at least in Spassky scamp
as Kroger's mentions perhaps the world
champion is resurrected and now he can
start looking into ways how to get back
into this match perhaps he will push for
the win now that Fischer is perhaps
weakened but perhaps he will simply I
tried to find a calm line to play with
the black pieces and then look for his
chances with the white pieces now what's
with this whole dark wine colored
costume idea as the Kogi's mentions
chess players you would think that they
are logical beans but most of the times
chess players will be very logical in
very superstitious so he mentions for
example Alexander Ali and a former World
Chess Champion he always had his Siamese
cat with him and he would always put
before the his game started he would put
his Siamese cat on the chess board to
either bring him luck or to you know
perhaps create an allergic reaction in
his opponent's at some point in the game
but at at that time I believe he didn't
know that Siamese cats were
hypoallergenic and I believe they are
and he also mentions however for example
solitaire tackler he refused to have his
photograph taken whenever he was playing
the game as he thought it was a bad luck
charm and so for the previous game in
game 11 Fischer came wearing a dark wine
colored costume as a gligar which puts
it and it was the only game Fischer
really really lost apart from in Game
one that he like we said beat himself in
Game two that he forfeited but game 11
Spassky really crushed him and everyone
thought that Fischer will not
where this same costume again but
official wear came wearing the exact
same costume for game 12 so it seems
official was not superstitious after all
at least in this case so without further
ado let's see how game 12 went and what
did Fisher decided to play E 4 d 4 C 4
or perhaps something else in this game
we have a similar line like we've
already seen in game 6 the Fisher opens
with c4 so what did Spassky prepare we
have e 6 again going for the timid line
and Knight to f3 b5 will have D for a
transposing into the Queens gambit
declined of course Knight to f6 Knight
to c3 Bishop to e7 g5 everything the
same as in game 6
we have h6 Bishop to h4 castles III and
here in game 6 Baskerville and c5 a very
sharp tartakov our line but here he
decides to go into a different line
Knight bd7 and okay rook 8 2 c1 a
fissure is developing his pieces and c6
now usually in every variation of the
Queens gambit declined
what black will always wait for White's
to develop his light square bishop and
only then will black capture on c4 you
don't want to play something like
captures and only did and then white can
capture Bishop rook captures on c4 and
he will bring the piece into the game
with tempo so he revs upon and it
develops a bishop to a very nice C 4
square this way but playing c6 you will
first wait for white to decide what to
do with the bishop and only now after
Fisher plays Bishop to d3
now Spassky captures Fischer captures on
c4 and now while there is already
opponent c6 now b5 with temple butcher
back to d3 and now a6 as possibly has to
protected the b5 point if he wants the
execute c5 here castling would be a bit
premature as here Spassky can push c5
immediately and if you get rid of this
week's e6 pawn without white achieving
anything you can simply start developing
leadership to be seven rupees coming to
see it and everything is fine for black
so Fisher doesn't allow this he doesn't
castle rather he attacks with a four and
okay we have beat captures on a4
a very nice idea as it forces Fisher to
capture back pushing before is not all
that impressive because after Bishop
captures on f6 Knight chapters on f6 you
get a Knight to e4 and white what is
okay here
but after if you blog doesn't capture
with the night if black hackers would to
the Jeep on then the black's pawn
structure is somewhat weakened but black
can hold this without a problem so after
a for instead of pushing we have B
captors on a for now forcing Fischer to
capture on a4 Knight captures on a4 and
now comes Queen to a5 so this comes with
check and it stops Fisher from castling
nice 2d to Fisher doesn't want to bring
this Knight back from a4 as the knife
from a4 very convenient cigars covers
the c5 square so for the time being
Fischer is preventing Spassky from
executing c5 we have Knights the d2
blocking check and now Bishop to b4
comes with a double attack against the
d2 Knight also prevents castling at
least for one more move slicer has to go
back Knight to c3 and the now Spassky
executes c5 and now always well in
blacks camp as possibly got to rid of
his weakness on c6 and now it's time to
continue this game nice to be three by
Fischer we have Queen back to the edge
by Spassky you have to bring the Queen
back although it's pretty not very
convenient you know going under the
bishops mask but it's not a problem for
now now Fischer takes this opportunity
to castle we have C capture Sun d4
Knight captures on d4 and now Bishop to
b7 Spassky very nicely develops the
bishop and here Bishop to e4 here
Fischer is controlling the c6 square
he's hoping for Knight to c6 and Spassky
has to do something you don't want to
allow this either force afraid of
bishops or the force knight c6 the e7
check so here Queen to b8 a very nice
move now if you go something like nice
to see six well you can play this for
some reason Fischer doesn't go for this
for example now you can go to d6 offer a
trade
of Queens but now Knight to e7 check
queen characters and now Bishop capture
some b7 you grab the bishop pair rook to
a7 and now you bring the bishop back so
this would in fact be okay for white but
Fischer has a different plan first
Bishop to g3 with an attack on the Queen
Queen to a7 and now comes Knight to c6
Bishop captures Bishop captures and now
rook a to c8 Knight to a4 by Fischer
with further control of the c5 Square
and now Knight the c5 is a very
interesting what still Fischer is
keeping an eye on c5 because if Knight
the c5 then Fischer can capture Knight
captures for example rook captures on c6
but this would be asking for too much
with would black because now Knight to
d7 it seems like a very nice move but
rook captures on c1 and now comes Knight
captures on f6 now G captures and now
Queen to g4 check King moves and now
rook captures on c1 black's pawn
structure is very weakened and why it
keeps a better position with a much
better chances so after Knight to a4 not
nice the c5 but rather developing the
other rook rook F to d8 we have
Bishop back to f3 official wants the
exchange at least one pair rooks to have
a better control of the open files and
then out comes a 5 a very nice move by
Spassky further again gaining further
protection to the bishop on before but
also it's very hard to bring the Queen
into the game because Fischer's bishops
are very powerful here so spassky's idea
is Queen to a6 the b-52 c6 after the
rooks to get exchange of course and
trying something with tonight's the
sorry instead of this a5 move if you try
nice to e5 yes you do open up a
discovered attack from the from the rook
to the Queen and also threatening to
capture one of the bishops the problem
is the Bishop captures on e5 and now if
you capture the Queen you get rook
captures on c8 with check King has to
move and now comes rook captures and
white will be winning here being up so
much material so after Bishop to f3 we
have a 5 like we already mentioned rook
the c6 and the now comes
captures on c6 Bishop captures on c6 and
now rook to c8 as passkey wants to gain
control of the C file as well but should
be back to f3 and the now comes Queen to
a6 as possibly now is preparing his a
maneuver with between b5 to c6 we have
h3 by Fischer and Queen to b5 now as
planned
Bishop to e2 with an attack on the Queen
and now comes Queen to c6 and now
Spassky has a very nice control of the C
file even though Fisher does have the
better prepare but spots keys pieces are
also very active mushroom back to f3
attacking the Queen and Queen back to F
b5 and here b3 Fischer doesn't want to
repeat with Bishop to e3 wouldn't attack
on the Queen so he plays b3 and make
some room for this night to be able to
enter the game but should be back to e7
we have Bishop to e2 attacking the Queen
once again Queen to b4 and now Bishop to
a6 would an attack on the rook rook the
c6 attacking the bishop and now bush it
back to d3 and the now comes nice to see
five and now if Knight captures on c5
this is playable but then rook captures
on c5 and after Bishop to c4 closing up
this C file and also protecting the pawn
it would be pretty much a droid flying
because now a four doesn't really do all
that much for black after Bishop to b6
would an attack on the rook and the
bishop Bishop captures Queen captures
it's it's a very nice position for white
there are a lot of threats on the back
rank also Bishop to d3 will be an idea
controlling h7 so you can't capture on
b3 or push a three for that matter
because of what we've just mentioned
Queen d8 check King gauge 7 and now
Bishop to d3 will be deadly if you put
g6 you'll lose the night and if you
block with something like tin nice to d4
then Queen to d4 is deadly with a double
attack on the knight and also your queen
is under attack you have to capture
Queen captures now after pawn captures
you can't protect both the night and the
rook
so after Knights the c5 instead of
capturing Queen to f3 by Fischer with an
attack against this rook and it seems to
give
Spassky a lot of
problems here glitch mentions night see
to afford to be an excellent move and in
fact it's very hard to see what a white
could play here it's an excellent score
for the night black doesn't even have to
do anything if he wishes he can capture
one of the bishops or perhaps a white
will capture here but regardless it
would be a very nice move for black and
the engine agrees with Glee good its
idea but Spassky it goes for a different
idea he simply moves the rook back
looked the c8 and now we have Knight
captures on c5 by Fischer Bishop
captures on c5 and now rook the c1 and
here if you play Queen captures on b3 it
doesn't work because of simply rook
captures on c5 rook captures and the
Queen to a to check the bishop is
guarding h7 once you give up all of your
pieces it will be checkmate so I have to
look to see one we have looked to d8 and
the now comes the Bishop to c4 simply
closing the C file and protecting his b3
pawn Queen to d2 by Spassky and now rook
to f1 not allowing took the Queen to
capture the rook Bishop to b4 and now
comes the Bishop to c7 with an attack on
the rook rook to d7 and now Queen to c6
we have Queen to c2 and the now comes
Bishop to e5 rook to d2 and now Queen to
eight with check we have King to h7 and
now Bishop captures an F on f6 possibly
saw this and he saw that his the
weakening of the King side will not do
all that much for Fischer G captures on
f6 and Queen back to f3 and okay Fischer
did achieve something he did open up the
King side a bit but he had to give up
his bishop repair in return f5 by
Spassky a very nice move locking on all
of his pawns on light squares as Fischer
does have a light square bishop so the
bishop will not be after her will not be
able to use the bishop few attacks pass
his King and here we have g4 Fischer
wants to keep the game going he wants to
keep fighting I forgot to mention sorry
about this after after spassky's rook to
d7 move Queen to c6 a Fischer's attack
here against the rook was the move
Fischer sealed so this is the 41st move
here the game was adjourned and then of
course the players again analyzed the
game the entire night and the game was
continued tomorrow but ok then like we
mentioned Queen to c2 pinning the bishop
we have Bishop to e5 preparing to
capture and then Spassky saw that this
was in fact alright captures captures
and Queen to f3 where we left off at 5
and g4 and now comes Queen to e4
offering a queen trade an interesting
move is a4 with the idea that ok you
cannot capture because Queen captures
here but then it doesn't work because of
a very nice idea
ah but feel free to pause the video here
as it's a it's a very nice idea for
white
what did black do by pushing a 4 so feel
free to pause the video here and find
the winning idea for white I'll give you
a couple of seconds if you want to
decide whether to do it or not so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you know you have just
taken advantage of this small inaccuracy
by and by Spassky it's actually Queen to
b7
for those who just want to enjoy the
show simply would an attack against the
f7 pawn and also by pushing a for the
bishop on b4 is now unguarded so
whatever you decide to do obviously will
protect your Bishop but then after Queen
captures on f7 you're also gonna lose
this exponent so on and so on
so after g4 Queen to e4 was played by
Spassky offering a queen trade and now
King to g2 official says ok for trade
Queen's I want to bring my King into the
game faster King to g6 by Spassky and
now rook to c1 we have Bishop to e3
attacking the rook rook to e1 attacking
the bishop bishop back to before and now
rook back to c1 and here as a glitch
mentions we have a little game of
prestige Spassky doesn't repeat Bishop
to a3 with the third move of repeating
he actually plays Bishop to e7
now Spassky wants to keep fighting and
he's threatening the bush up to h4 to
create some threats against the f2 pawn
so Fischer has to do something about
this he plays G captures on f5 with
check we have each afters on f5 and now
comes a rook to e1
now if the f4 f 2 point is under attack
rook to e2 will defend it but here
Spassky has a little combination that
Fischer allows simply to quicken the
draw rook captures on f2 with check the
Queen cannot capture as the Queen is
pencil King has the capture king capture
an f2 was played we have Bishop to h4
check King moves to e2 and now Queen
captures on f3 we have King captures on
f3 and here after Bishop captures anyone
unmoved 55 the players agreed to a draw
as its it's a four against the three but
the bishops are of opposite colors and
the both Fischer and Spassky know that
this will be played out to a draw as
black blacks f1 is doubled so there is
really nothing to do push for here so
that's a game 12 of the 1972 World Chess
Championship match between Robert James
Fischer and Boris is pasque-dieu hope
you enjoyed it and game 13 will also be
a very nice game so you know hope you
will enjoy that as well I would like to
thank guilt right son Miriam is calling
Danny McCulloch Steven Jordan and one
Vincente Alvarez for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here think all for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content thank you all and I'll see you
soon